this week an incredibly damning new book
about president trump came out
by renowned journalist bob woodward and
that's the
third third negative trump book out this
month alone
there are two others from trump's former
attorney michael cohen
and melania's former best friend i
cannot think of another president who's
had this many negative books come out
while still in office andy do you have
any of these books
actually conan i have all of them and
you can too
by joining the trump book of the day
club every day you'll receive a new book
about the president and his family
often written by someone with deep
inside knowledge
and always painting a devastating
portrait of an
unfit lunatic let loose in the white
house you'll get titles like these
oval office square colon the medical
records of donald trump
destroyed 600 trump jokes that in the
end did nothing
imagine you're a walrus and other ways
to get through sex by melania trump
remember me no that's okay i still have
a lot of dirt on trump by omarosa
not proofread just trying to [ __ ] this
book out before the
electron by carl bernstein what a douche
by pope francis
a lifetime of unthinkable abuse by
donald trump's gold toilet
i went to high school with ivanka not
the same year but i heard she was kind
of mean
by jennifer flack becoming by melania
trump with michelle obama
of course i'm a lunatic by donald
trump's doctor
celt and pooper melania's weird
pronunciations of common spices
by a white house chef he's a terrible
person
and that's coming for me the literal
devil by stephen bannon
wasn't doing much thought i'd write a
trump book by dean kane
seven melanias written by the seven
identical septuplets who play melania
trump
i'll make you a star kid the pep talk i
gave to the coronavirus
by president donald j trump how to make
a rose garden racist somehow
by white house gardener steve gillis
girl interrupted by mike pence
and finally mushroom penises make
mushroom clouds
by stormy daniels the trump book of the
day club
it never stops never even like when you
think well this is the one that will
totally sink the guy
surely this is the last account i'll see
of his corruption cruelty
and total incompetence no there is no
bottom
happy reading everyone